THE DNC REPORTEDLY ANOTHER RULE
CHANGE THAT JOE BIDEN LOVES TO
SIT DURING THE DEBATE RATHER
THAN STAND.
WE WILL SEE.
BY THE WAY, CONGRESS WOMAN
TULSI GABBARD JOINS US TONIGHT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR COMING ON.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THIS?
YOU MUST HAVE THE TELEVISION ON
AND YOU WALK THROUGH THE AIRPORT
AND YOU HEAR PEOPLE SAY NO WOMEN
IN THE RACE.
I’M IN THE RACE.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THAT?
>> HI, I’M HERE.
YOU ARE RIGHT.
IT HAPPENED MORE THAN ONCE,
WORKING -- WALKING THROUGH
AIRPORTS AND HAPPEN TO SEE A
TELEVISION ON, AND IT IS
ACTUALLY A DISSERVICE TO THE
VOTERS, REALLY IS WHAT IS
HAPPENING HERE.
DISRESPECTING VOTERS IN THIS
COUNTRY AND THEIR ABILITY TO
MAKE THE BEST INFORMED DECISION
ABOUT WHO THEY WOULD LIKE TO SEE
MOVE FORWARD IN THE DEMOCRATIC
NOMINEE.
AND REALLY IT BEGS THE QUESTION,
WHY ARE THEY DOING THIS?
WHY IS THE POLITICAL ELITE IN
WASHINGTON AND CORPORATE MEDIA
PARTNERS, WHY ARE THEY
CONTINUING TO TRY TO ERASE MY
CANDIDACY, TO TRY TO STOP VOTERS
FROM HEARING THE MESSAGE THAT
I’M CONTINUING TO BRING TO THE
FOREFRONT THAT BEGAN THE VERY
FIRST DAY THAT I ANNOUNCE MY
CANDIDACY FOR PRESIDENCY IS TO
ATTEMPT TO BLACKOUT, SMEAR MY
CAMPAIGN, MY CANDIDACY.
IT IS NOT A MYSTERY.
WHY I’M RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT IS
TO BRING ABOUT A SEA CHANGE IN
OUR FOREIGN POLICY BECOME A
SEA CHANGE THAT SAYS WE WILL END
THESE WASTEFUL REGIME CHANGE
WARS AND STOP GOING AROUND THE
WORLD, TRYING TO BE THE WORLDS
POLICE TOPPLING DICTATORS AND TO
NUCLEAR ARMS RACE ALL OF WHICH
ARE NOT MAKING US ANY SAFER
AND INSTEAD REDIRECT THE TAX
PAYER DOLLARS ACTUALLY TOWARD
SERVING THE NEEDS OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE HERE AT HOME.
THEY DON’T LIKE DEALING WITH THE
CORONAVIRUS, THINGS LIKE
INVESTING IN EDUCATION,
HEALTH CARE, PORTABLE HOUSING,
URGENT NEEDS THAT PEOPLE HAVE.
THIS IS THE CHANGE I SEEK TO
BRING ABOUT.
IT IS NOT A MYSTERY AND THIS IS
WHY AM RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE DESERVE TO
KNOW WHY THOSE IN POWER DON’T
WANT THEM TO HEAR THIS MESSAGE.
>> Tucker: IT WAS MEETING WITH
THE SIDE.
WHICH I THOUGHT WAS GREAT.
A SOLID, NOT ENDORSING HIM BUT
HE PROJECTED -- PROTECTED
CHRISTIANS, AND YOU HAVE A RIGHT
TO MAKE THAT POINT.
THEY HAVE NOT LET YOU MAKE THAT
POINT OR ANY POINT.
THEY JUST DISMISS YOU BECAUSE OF
THAT.
WE DON’T HAVE MUCH TIME BUT WHAT
IS THAT ABOUT?
IT IS BIZARRE.
>> IT IS A DANGEROUS SITUATION
THAT WE ARE IN THAT SO MANY
PEOPLE HERE IN WASHINGTON WHO
ARE PART OF THIS POWERFUL ELITE
WHO HAVE THE STRANGLEHOLD OVER
THE FOREIGN POLICY ESTABLISHMENT
ARE SO AFRAID OF DIPLOMACY.
AND THEY CAST OUT PEOPLE LIKE ME
WHO ARE CALLING FOR A FOREIGN
POLICY FOCUSED ON COOPERATION
AND DIPLOMACY RATHER THAN
CONFRONTATION AS SOMETHING WEIRD
OR BAD OR TO BE SUSPICIOUS OF.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT SO MANY LEADERS
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY’S HISTORY
WHO HAVE MADE THOSE TOUGH
DECISIONS TO EXERCISE DIPLOMACY
TO PREVENT THE COUNTRY FROM
UNNECESSARILY GOING TO WAR.